コニーちゃん初めて長と正木取締役と皆さんどうも大きさでございます
まきさんはなんといっても特殊メイクの湯中バーですよねそうですねはい白目のメイク
とかトーキョーグールの顔とか本当にて国車
すごい
うまいっ
まあまあ特殊免疫ですぐ上手なのでもうぺらぼうメイクって作れますかって聞いたん
です
作れますけど開かせてくださいしまーさーんっ今回はきたさんに正木を
のっぺらぼうにしてもらって一つ縁なんでしょ滑りプレーにあってああああ知っなら
路線っても軟化した
来るなって流れてるんで逆に正英こんなにとっているしたけどいると思います
俺何かもん
んですか
じゃあこれはそのままことよりこっちだけはございません
いい気なもんだな
うっ
ん
ねわからない8回がいなかった
9続けた色花だと限界
えっ
んん
me
ああああああ
おおすごい
[音楽]
ん
wh
分
おっ
[音楽]
ああああああ
裏毛できたありがとうございます完成しました
愛というわけでこれからターゲットが来るんですけどもうちょっと怖い雰囲気で部屋を
ずっと管グストいって何気なく雅紀をポットを置いといてバット振り返ったら
ポピュラーだったっていう怖いよねー驚かすてみようと思いますチョッピングだあれ
さあ
.
てぬあれね分かんねぇ
化してるっなんですよ
[音楽]
[拍手]
うん
ああああああ
うわーっ
me
teame
re だった
うわっ何食べるつまり
た